this is what I hope to see when I die
and we all know who doesn't love fried
chicken
if you want to seduce me just offer me
fried chicken and I'm like that
everyone's gonna win today because it's
fried chicken except like your
cholesterol levels and your arteries
this is less some off-brand chicken it's
good buttery it's good it's fun
necessarily doesn't have that much of a
crunch to it
dark meat it's patties richard slowly
various sounds pretty good I give it
like an 8 out of 10 I like really really
crispy chicken so I give it a 5
oh this smells good like the altai
doesn't leave that oily but once you go
inside it's looks like a vat of oil
chickens just a little dry for my taste
oh this is spicy feels like the skin and
the chicken are do different things you
I don't like that that's the light this
is me baby Popeyes it's got that nice
little Popeyes flavor 5 out of 10 would
not eat again if these weren't part of
me already 100% sure this is KFC mmm oh
you're chicken oh I just got a huge bite
agree this one made my spit really stick
to the chicken is like all the way I dig
this maaan this maybe first place
scenario oh this is pretty good but I
don't think it's as good as Roscoe's or
no this tastes to me like the most
processed so far we can mostly Burgundy
you know I'm switching a bike because I
might not eat dinner right you just say
take me to church I like this one this
one is very very grateful it came like
straight straight from the fire I hope I
don't get like diarrhea this is
definitely the best way best part to it
yeah really why I don't like that I
don't know what this brand is but I'm
not it maybe this was the church one
there's too much there's not even
chicken anymore just fried skin you're
some skin on your lip
smell that I like the skin that flavor
yes one was like the perfect dessert to
the rest of things look at how much
chicken as well like this is this came
from an Anthony no this one this
seasoned really really well [ __ ] I'm
Omar [ __ ] you Josh winner winner chicken
dinner
boom oh that one Louisiana Popeyes KFC
churches Rock Morocco's Roscoe's Popeyes
KFC churches Louisiana we're all right
[ __ ] your head alright yeah yeah
we're boys we're boys you like chicken
boys we're boys who like [ __ ] fried
chicken pick the chicken up take the big
bite little down be blowing good night
whoa